yep we are recording
and welcome to Whiskey politics episode
113 I'm Dave Sussman your host and
prevaire at whiskeypolitics.net where we
interview luminaries newsmakers and
insiders find our series at ricochet.com
and every podcast application including
iTunes and we ask you to subscribe and
give whiskey politics a five-star rating
and a comment if you're enjoying the
show also we have an announcement coming
soon where you'll be able to find our
show on the TV so stay tuned oh if
you're on Twitter you can follow me also
at David Sussman
you know as we talk about on the show
quite a lot uh we talk about political
correctness Progressive thought and
dogma and the attack on free speech and
how it's permeated all corners of our
culture uh from journalism to Academia
to Media but what about the hard
Sciences
um we all know how it's impacted the
discussion about climate change as we
discussed with Princeton's Dr William
Hopper recently which you can find at
whiskeypolitics.net it's uh Shameless
plug there uh but uh that's where he
discussed the dogma of consensus the
science is settled approach pretty much
ends all debate but unfortunately
further to a new book by Our Guest today
Brian Keating it doesn't end just at
climate change
Brian Keating is a professor of physics
at the center of astrophysics uh and
space Sciences uh named Cas and is that
is in the department of physics at the
University of California San Diego he's
a public speaker an inventor and an
expert in the study of the universe's
oldest light the cosmic microwave
background the CMB and using it to learn
about the origin and evolution of the
universe he's written from many
Publications including the Scientific
American and is about to be the first
speaker at prageru if I if I'm correct
here from the hard Sciences Brian's new
book losing the Nobel Prize the story of
cosmology ambition and The Perils of
Sciences highest honor discusses the
politics of Alfred Nobles life-changing
award welcome Brian
hi Dave great to be with you thanks for
joining us listen uh I got your book
last night and as I was just discussing
I was heading to a discussion group so
other than a cursory overview this
morning I haven't had the pleasure of
reading the whole thing but uh
beforehand I I did have a chance to take
a look at a lot of your work and find
much of what you talk about really is
important in today's environment where
discussion of Science and religion can
bring out some really strong opinions in
fact part of last night's discussion at
this group that I was at was right along
with what you talk about in your prageru
video that's upcoming I don't know if
it's out quite yet is it uh on its way
out uh I think it's going to air in
April late April um there's a preview
there's a preview of it on the web on
prageru currently but yeah the full
episode the full course uh which is
entitled Faith the final frontier that's
coming later in the in the spring in
about a few weeks in April Love It
little William Shatner in that
um so you talk about the origins of the
universe the Big Bang how it intersects
with religion the Bible and Genesis and
I'd love to hear your thoughts on all of
this but first of all how did you end up
in Prague which up till now is more or
less shied away from the hard Sciences
yeah so I followed Dennis Prager for
many years he's been a real kind of
influential uh thinker and and writer in
terms of my non-academic research and as
I went into the field of writing a
popular science book you know for a
public Mass audience as I've done that
uh I found that some of his influences
were trickling into a book you know
which kind of surprised me that it was
about a book about the hard Sciences a
book about the origin of the universe
and and how the notion of the origins of
the universe has kind of become
conflated and can almost be broken down
by party lines which is which is kind of
a shocking surprising to me in a way
that we can discuss but uh as I as I you
know approach this I kept hearing you
know Dennis speak about how uh almost
almost as a badge of honor that you know
they had no uh speakers from the hard
Sciences of course as you mentioned
William Hopper he's an eminent uh
physicist at Princeton University and uh
so they've had speakers that are hard
scientists but uh but never one that
really addressed the the biggest picture
of them all as far as I can tell you
know namely how did we all get here and
so this video that I proposed basically
made a pitch to Alan Estrin and and
Dennis Prager based on the you know
forthcoming book and they were very
interested in it and so uh time went
along and I worked very intensely with
their staff and they've got a really uh
first-rate production staff there what
was the Crux of the video so the video
explores a new paradigm that's emerging
in my subfield of cosmology which is as
you know the study of hair and makeup
and how it's it's the study of the
origin of the universe and how do we get
here and I make the point in the in the
video that um for you know Millennia
religious Believers uh have have had to
accept much of what their particular
religious Doctrine says based on faith
and and and maybe pure faith I mean
there's people that have had Direct uh
you know Revelations and and have had
Jesus you know appear to them and speak
to them and and I don't you know deny
how they how they've experienced that
but but besides those you know kind of
one-on-one experiences there hasn't been
Mass Revelation and you know thousands
of years right so so you had to really
take a lot on faith and and that's okay
and I think there's there's you know
there's there's principles of faith and
in my religion of Judaism and
Christianity as well and I think that's
that's a wonderful thing however in The
Sciences more and more needs to be taken
on faith to understand and and really to
to sort of interpret the data that we're
getting about the very first moments of
the universe and as I did more more and
more research into it I found that most
most of my colleagues in fact the
overwhelming majority of the members of
the National Academy of Sciences the
most prestigious scientific organization
some say in the world and certainly
within the United States seventy percent
of them declare that they do not believe
in God and yeah 70 70 and you know the
dominant share of Nobel Prize winners uh
and Etc and so uh throughout the course
of my book I came to found that there
was an inextricable uh linking between
one's sort of religious Viewpoint and
and their uh their choice of
interpretation of the data that the
early Universe presented and so my video
explores the fact that you know there's
things that you don't have to take on
evident like on faith like gravity I
don't believe in the law of gravity I
have evidence for the law of gravity
right right will rise in the east but I
have evidence that the sun will rise in
these on the other hand there's no
evidence for this extremely early uh
Epoch of the universe that's called uh
that's called the Multiverse which
suggests that there's perhaps not one or
two or three other universes in
existence but that there's an Infinity
of other universes and that has obvious
implications for the faithful The Devout
and even the atheist and I think when uh
when people discuss this you can see how
the breakdown comes along uh atheists
versus theist lines and that to me
belies the fact of of there not being a
true scientific
passion maybe underlying their
motivations so I sort of suggest in the
video that scientists need to be a
little bit more intellectually honest
and ironically you know from their
perspective it's the religious who are
being the intellectually honest ones
that they admit well we don't have proof
of the origin of the universe by uh
knowing loving personal God but we take
it on faith and now these you know
predominantly non-believers scientists
are you know kind of willing to accept
the theory for which they have no
evidence
so whether it's an atheist or a leftist
or whatever it may be uh and however you
want to classify it they seem to be in
control of not only the hard sciences
and culture but also all of academics
today are you able to talk with your
colleagues about this it's it's it's
it's depressingly difficult I remember I
came you know came to school the day
after the election of Donald Trump and I
heard a lot of my colleagues in the art
sciences bemoaning and bewailing the
fact that that Trump won and then they
were arguing with some were arguing with
others and I knew that they were both
hardcore leftists and uh what could they
possibly be arguing about neither one of
them voted for Trump I mean maybe a
protest Vote or something like that but
it turned out they were going you know
going at each other's throats because
one had voted for Bernie as a write-in
and that yeah and you know I mean in
California your vote for you know for a
republican is basically as you know uh a
waste but but nevertheless and and you
know I don't I don't ever bring politics
into the classroom I don't I don't think
my colleagues do as well well on the
other hand I feel like
um there's such a uniformity of thinking
that even in the hard sciences that the
you know overwhelming majority more much
more than 70 percent of my colleagues in
physics and chemistry in math and
computer science you know have an
outright just disdain not not just for
Trump okay I can understand why people
you know have their issues with Trump
and and I was certainly not a supporter
of him you know uh uh for most of the
Electoral cycle I was backing other
other folks but in the end I felt that
you know they're they're they're it's
difficult to have conversations with
people who really believe that if you
don't hold not just a liberal
perspective I mean think Liberals are
wonderful but if you don't hold a truly
you know relatively radical in my
opinion left left orientation that
you're somehow not worthy of discussion
or debate and it's very hard to have a
collegial debate with somebody who
really you know kind of rebukes your
your standpoint uh just just on the face
of it and this was true by the way for
Trump when this goes back to George W
bush I I won an award from George W bush
at the White House and I have a picture
in my office of me shaking his hand and
one of my colleagues came in and
basically left my office he's like how
dare you have this picture of George W
bush in your office you know I mean he's
his mass murderer I mean it's just you
can't have a conversation with people
like that yeah yeah now I don't want to
say it's as bad as it is in the social
sciences much worse we have a we have a
cafeteria here on campus just to give
you an idea called the che Cafe so and
that's you know no yep your tax dollars
go to support the che Cafe with pictures
of Angela seriously oh yeah you can come
visit that's at UCSD maybe he'll do an
onsite here yeah and UCSD used to be one
of the more conservative of the UC
campuses
um or just moderate rather it still is
you know much more moderate than a a
murderous communist dictator yep that
led to the deaths of countless countless
P really yeah that's that's incredible
to me I didn't know that well you know
best of all you'll be thrilled to know
that your your taxpayers are going to
renovate it so you can enjoy uh you know
your your lack of control over how your
tax dollars are spent in the state of
California because we're undergoing it's
undergoing a massive renovation ah jeez
you know this is where the dichotomy is
for me uh an understanding science
because I you would think scientists
think rationally and and and the best
predictor of future behaviors past
behaviors of course and if you take a
look at economic systems and political
systems around the world obviously
leftism has led to the you know poverty
and the slaughter of millions and tens
of hundreds of millions of people over
the years don't scientists think
rationally well I think that's a common
misconception I think scientists or
subject men are experts so if you were
to ask me
because I remember
if you were to ask me what um you know
what I feel about global warming I think
the the most uh scientifically uh you
know to act in a way with scientific
Integrity I should say I'm not an expert
and it's extremely complex go talk to
somebody like uh Professor happer or
somebody here at Scripps Institute of
oceanography who's an expert on the
other side because I think that's the
truly scientific way to approach things
I am an astrophysicist I am a
cosmologist just like you shouldn't ask
them about what was the you know
Multiverse alike and and how did the
universe emerge from nothing into
nothing so um so I think scientists can
be very rational in their field of
subject matter expertise but you know
one thing I point out in my book is how
every every so often they Trot out the
New York Times or whoever trots out you
know 60 Nobel Prize winners advise you
on who to vote for and it's really I
always joke it's which Democrat to vote
for you know it's never been and these
are Nobel Prize winners and and very
very
um Arcane aspects of of quantum physics
six of of what's called condensed matter
you know very Arc they have no knowledge
of of say the Iran deal that's the
opinion or even you know I ask what
relevance does a astrophysicist
cosmologist one of my colleagues who won
the Nobel Prize what knowledge does he
really have of GMOs you know and which
which I'm fine I agree with his position
but but to trot them out as a symbol of
authority belies the fact that science
you know scientists are looked at as if
they're superhuman and robots and we're
really not and and and I explore this
these themes as well because I think
it's a common misconception a stereotype
that's that really does a disservice but
in in the defense of science you know we
do have an obligation of society's
Defenders of reason to be dispassionate
and I I fear that that we often lose
that and kind of degenerate into just
the normal kind of standard uh debates
without from emotional standpoints that
an ordinary you know non-scientist you
know citizen would would devolve into
yeah yeah and I want to talk about your
book and in just a moment uh fascinating
uh much of what is taught in the
classroom today as you talk about is
tinged with political bias and you're
what you're telling me is that that's
also an issue at The Graduate level in
the hard Sciences
um so if you're talking about and and
this goes back to your expertise the
origins of the universe uh there's a lot
of
um uh
intersectionality I hate that term now
holy cow God and co-opted by yeah yeah
exactly uh but there is an intersection
with religion
um what is the dialogue like with fellow
scientists on that well I think it
depends you know it depends on the
individual scientists so you know not
all my colleagues are you know rabid
leftists and not not you know very few
of them are you know conservative in the
traditional you know JFK sense maybe it
being a conservative or liberal a
classic Big Al liberal exactly
um and and you know as I said it's not
as it's not as rampant in my you know I
think in the literature Department in
the sociology Department my colleagues
over there uh you know we just agree not
to talk about politics and and that's
fine and and I don't think that they
would really care what I have to say and
it's not as if you know someone who's a
a poet really is going to listen to a
scientist just because he's a scientist
if he's talking about something that
violates their preconceived notion of
what is fair what is just and and you
know speaks to the political correctness
that they themselves subscribe to have
our biases uh and so I think I think
it's important to note that
um you know my colleagues at least are
not teaching this in class uh but you
should note that there's not like some
big building where we all get together
you know The Faculty Club we all get
together and just you know have have our
robes on and have these debates about
politics it's more it's more subtle I
mean yeah but again it's not nowhere
near as bad I think as as I've been told
from my colleagues in the social
sciences
and what's it like for you personally I
mean obviously you're out there you have
your opinions you're in the media you've
written articles uh has there been a
response from your fellow uh professors
um and and you know the the the the
administration at all no no I mean I
think there there's you know there's a
virtue in in the tenure system um I'm
personally not for the 10-year system uh
in most cases I think that that uh the
10 years that protects you it it it does
in a sense but you know I wonder how
many of the academic colleagues
including myself would be doing
something other than this if we somehow
didn't have tenure and I know many great
scientists who don't have tenure
um I know many great scientists who
never went to graduate school and and
these are people that are you know
eminent eminent thinkers and so I don't
think that tenure in in certain Fields I
think the tenure protects the university
in certain cases from us leaving after
they've invested a lot of money you know
when I was hired by the University of
California they gave me a generous
amount of money to build a laboratory to
hire students to train those students to
get their phds and and I'm proud to say
I've graduated nine PhD students from
you know almost every continent and I've
worked with people around the world and
and that's my obligation to them but you
know if I wasn't if I was if I lost my
job I um you know I'm quite confident
that I could find a job in the technical
field which would probably pay a lot
more than I'd get in Academia so I think
in this in the hard Sciences it's it's
unnecessary I think in the soft Sciences
or in the in the social sciences it
leads to a lot of you know quite frankly
nonsense that go that passes for
scholarship
um you know there's rabid you know kind
of anti-israel sentiment that's really
um you know kind of sponsored by by say
even the judaic studies Department here
and other other institutions UCSD is by
no means unique it's uh there is a very
powerful you know Core group of
intellectuals who are very wise people
in their subject matter but outside of
it I really don't suspect that they have
much you know kind of a general overall
knowledge and you know I'd love to have
debates but but of course it's it's you
know it's It's tricky to prevent those
from devolving into into attacks so my
favorite anecdote was I was I was
walking around on campus one day and I
saw this I saw this big tent and it was
all you know yay for Israel and it was
all these students
um and they weren't they weren't Jewish
they weren't Israeli they were Asians
they were there were people from from
um you know just not you know Gentiles
from from all different countries and I
asked them what what are you guys are
you like you know Jews for Jesus Jesus
for Jews what are you guys doing right
like no we're the we're the uh GOP Club
of of UCSD and I didn't even know such a
thing existed but I just thought it was
so interesting that they chose to to
devote their time their their and their
you know their money to to you know kind
of protesting the the anti-israel
sentiment that was going on on campus
and does go on on campus every year yeah
yeah
um I think yeah you know it's it's one
of the things is that you know we talk
about uh conservatism today is almost
the last Bastion of free speech and
protection of free speech and whether
it's uh stopping uh you know folks
coming to different uh campuses you know
from the conservatives or the BDS
movement with Israel or whatever it is I
think you see a lot of that uh a lot of
the folks coming together to prevent the
the I mean
yeah I think that's probably one of the
greatest threats of our time right now
is is is you are not allowed to talk
about this particular issue because it
goes against or it's offending us or
whatever it may be Israel being one of
them and BDS and everything else so uh I
think um you know you you use the word
big tent uh I think it could relate to
um what we see on the right today as
trying to
bring everybody together so we can at
least have this dialogue we should have
this discussion now talking about
discussion and dialogue I want to talk
about your book
because
um it's it's it's really an interesting
perspective on what a lot of people
especially those of us on the right or
right of Center libertarian leading have
felt somewhat uncomfortable with over
the past several years and that is the
Nobel Prize and how it's awarded your
your book losing the Nobel Prize a com
let me see here a story of cosmology
ambition and The Perils of science's
highest honor
um I want to geek out with you a little
bit on this uh I barely remember my high
school physics courses so you're gonna
have to share with us a little bit
um but if you were to write Cosmic
microwave polarization for dummies right
uh can you explain that for our audience
yeah so um The Cosmic microwave
background is a glowing Remnant it's the
only glowing Remnant it's the only
Remnant at all if you like a fossil of
the forging of the elements of which
were made so the universe We Believe
began with a big bang and and in the in
the year five thousand no it began 13.8
billion years ago uh with a very
accurate measurement that that my
colleagues and I have been working on
for years and we now know the age of the
universe to a fantastic Precision
equivalent to me like never knowing you
meeting you at random and guessing your
birth day and your birth hour uh you
know exactly so uh so we've learned a
tremendous about about the universe and
one of the facts of the universe is that
we are continually being uh cooked in a
microwave oven and this microwave oven
thank goodness is only set at a
temperature of about minus 400 degrees
below zero fahrenheit or else we would
feel it so it's overwhelmed by the
temperature of say the sun which is our
nearest Celestial
um uh source of energy so uh but if you
were to go back and and look out in
space where there's no sun there's no
Planet there's no other star or Galaxy
in your way you're looking back in space
but you're also looking back in time and
if you look back where there's nothing
getting in your way and there there's no
other things in the foreground so to
speak you'll look back to the oldest
Cosmic light and that is the relic of
the big bang and it's called The Cosmic
microwave background
this was discovered in 1965 by two
astronomers who weren't looking for it
and that's a big theme in my book that
the the scientific achievements that we
should be looking for and even in in in
sort of personal uh regard of looking
you know in the social sciences are ways
that we actually observe Something
serendipitously That We're Not setting
out to discover something and then
saying Eureka I have found it you know
I've because those things are subject to
the most natural and most oldest of
human desires you know maybe second or
third all this and that's confirmation
bias that I have an opinion about
something and I want to confirm it to be
true whether that be that the Universe
had a beginning as as say you know the
faithful might say or that it had no
beginning or it's Eternal so if you
these folks discovered it in 1965
serendipitously and it resulted in Nobel
Prize 13 years later this heat is also
encodes all the matter all the energy
that has flowed throughout the Universe
since its earliest existence and that's
what my experiment which I have located
at the South whole Antarctica was
designed to do to go beyond just the
light waves that we see and see these
you know mysterious waves of gravity
that are thought to permeate the even
earlier Universe when the universe was
at less than a trillionth of a second
old
now I again going back to my high school
days this is Albert Einstein stuff right
correct yes yes so Einstein actually
believed that the Universe was eternal
and even though his equations led him to
a clear conclusion that he should have
recognized that the Universe could not
be static you can't have a static
universe according to his own you know
equations however when Hubble of the
famous Edwin Hubble after which the
Hubble Space Telescope name that
astronomer showed him unequivocal
evidence that the Universe was not only
not static but it was getting bigger
every second every year every Millennium
so what Einstein then did was something
extremely valorous and he said I was
wrong it was my greatest blunder is that
I didn't recognize that the universe is
actually should be expanding and I had
this preconceived bias this this
confirmation that I want to or this bias
I want to confirm that the Universe was
static for some reason or another I
don't know exactly why but nevertheless
he was uh you know he was uh
intellectually and honest enough to
admit it when he did that we we you know
were inexorably
um drawn to a conclusion that the
universe is expanding in time therefore
it must have been smaller in the past so
if you ran the movie backwards if you
think about it in that way if
everything's getting closer and closer
together I don't mean that you and I are
going to get closer together on things
on Earth but galaxies distant galaxies
that are moving away from Contracting or
the universe is expanding currently that
means if you went back in time to
earlier times things were closer
together and you could actually okay so
it's expanding still it's expanding
right now and the expansion's getting
faster but if you go if you ran the
movie backwards
then at time equals zero all the matter
in the universe was at one single point
and that point in that moment is called
the Big Bang the question is what caused
the big bang and that's the question my
experiment bicep was designed to answer
and we thought we did answer it and the
the aftermath of that announcement and
Discovery launched me on a quest that
not only sort of faced me or forced me
to confront my motivations for doing
what I do as a scientist but also the
role that the Nobel Prize is having not
just in in the in peace or economics or
or or you know the the medicine or
subjects like that but in my field the
hard Sciences in physics and chemistry
and what I found was rather shocking
so this was an announcement that took
place and it was a success that took
place in 2014 is that correct yeah that
was what we believed yes okay and when
this came out and this was your
experiment you were barely mentioned if
I read correctly yeah so what happened
was I had been the originating you know
kind of pioneer of this experiment
called bicep when I was what's called a
postdoc so after you get your PhD and if
you want to become a professor you have
to do a stint sort of in this no man's
land called called a postdoctoral uh
fellowship and I was a postdoc at
Caltech working with a very eminent uh
astrophysicist named Andrew Lang and
Andrew was a great supporter of my ideas
and allowed me to kind of
um explore the the possibility of
building an experiment located at the
South Pole and that experiment would be
the definitive measurement of the
universe's earliest moments uh along the
way we built more and more advanced
versions of the bicep telescope and the
second version of it was called bicep
two and that experiment was located at
the South Pole and immediately after we
deployed it to Antarctica the most cold
high dry forbidding landscape on the
earth the uh this this leader this
friend this mentor to me Andrew Lane
committed suicide
so my you know he's almost like a father
figure to me in many ways and that's
brutal for you yeah it was really
devastating and you know part of the
hope I hope that part of the service of
my book is to encourage other scientists
to seek help because it's a very high
pressure field especially when you're
seeking to win the greatest Accolade not
just in science but in all of humanity
so um So eventually other leaders and by
the time I had uh uh you know we he had
committed suicide I had moved to UC San
Diego from Caltech and the people that
were left at Caltech decided that nah
there wasn't much room left for me in
this experiment anymore and you know
part of that I I don't you know get into
the details of it but you know it it
part of me wondered at the time uh
whether or not it was because you know
there's only a limited number of people
that can win a Nobel Prize each year
which is one of its major failings and
right right ensure that uh you know I I
speculate at the time that that might
have been an underlying motivation but
um but no one will ever be sure yeah
yeah now as I said I didn't get a chance
to read the entire book uh but I did
peruse through it so explain for us if
you can the process of the nomination I
saw the invitation in in the beginning
of the book share with us how that works
yeah so so Not only was I you know sort
of a Nobel aspirant myself and for many
years you know much to my later regret I
I was aspiring at all costs to win the
Nobel Prize and it became sort of a
source of of the identity of a scientist
and I was told things like oh to get
tenure you have to be you know kind of
on the short list to win a Nobel Prize
so not only did I create this experiment
which was you know which would if
correct would have won a Nobel Prize
it's not clear if I would have won it or
lost it and hence part of the title but
the other aspect of the title is double
entender nature is that what's wrong
with the Nobel Prize should be gotten
rid of we should lose those aspects of
the Nobel Prize one of those is the
nomination process so in 2015
uh after the after the affair that I
described uh regarding the bicep
experiment took place and sort of
reached its day new month I was asked
just completely serendipitously to
nominate the next year's winners of the
Nobel Prize and in the letter they
invited me uh to to nominate people and
I share the letter in the book and they
said under no circumstances share this
letter so I think you know my chances of
a second nomination are pretty slim uh
and the other thing they helpfully added
was you know don't know you can't
nominate yourself so I said oh that's
you know thanks for reducing the
applicant pool for me so my task was to
nominate people other than myself that
were deserving winners of the Nobel
Prize in physics for the year 2016. when
I got this letter though uh you know I'm
an academic okay so what do I do I I do
primary source research so I went back
to Alfred nobel's will and I said what
are this uh all dead guy what did he
want with his will what did he want his
money to go to what did he want his name
to go to and what I found was really
shocking because what he wanted was that
the Nobel Prize should award a single
person who created something that
benefited all of mankind in the
preceding year
and I started to think well what kinds
of things in astronomy benefit all of
mankind or what kinds of things in
condensed matter physics you know this
physics of fluids and solids and and
it's it's kind of a stretch and then
certainly there had been things that had
been discovered decades ago that that
waited for decades to be nominated so on
one hand you know one of the worst
things you can do for somebody to
somebody's memory is to disavow what
they explicitly wish for in their will
right so if you're the executor of a
will and you don't and you don't execute
the the deceased you know desires you
know you could be sued Etc and I started
to think well what if you know what if
this Nobel committee got sued uh for
violating the express you know written
handwritten intent of Alfred Nobel which
he wrote them in 1895. he died just the
year after he wrote it down
and then to my great surprise I found
that not only has the Nobel Prize you
know committee been sued but they'd been
sued by people who had won the Peace
Prize you know so there's an old joke
you know by Stephen right you know I'd
kill to win a Nobel Peace Prize but he
were these very very aggressive uh Nobel
laureates you know kind of uh yeah yeah
and they were attacking because they
claimed that it was in violation of
Alfred nobel's will for the express
written purposes as he delineated and I
found well not only is that true in the
Peace Prize so they're also violating
what he wants done in a physics prize as
well so my book is written and I've
created an online community with some
colleagues called losing the
nobelprize.org in order to Advocate and
to petition and send petitions to the
Nobel Committee in Sweden to change
their their way of acting and I think
they there are a lot of things that are
done that are done uh to the detriment
of young people in science to women in
science to minorities in science and I
feel that this is a uh this is a time
for reform before the Nobel Prize like
the Hollywood uh you know metoo movement
or the you know the political kind of
upheaval that we see
um it could be just a matter of time
before the Nobel Prize loses this this
Allure that it's had for way over a
century yeah and I want to ask you about
the competitive aspect on science itself
but you refer to the Peace Prize and I I
did see in the book that you you refer
to President Barack Obama he'd been on
the job for what 11 days or something
when they and and so you know obviously
he got the he got the Nobel Peace Prize
in 29 or 10. I'm not sure which year it
is 2009 yeah 2009. uh and and use quote
here and I've I've got this down here
somewhere you said some said that he
hadn't even had time to measure the
proverbial drapes in the Oval Office let
alone have reduced the world standing
armies the Criterion Nobel uh would have
stipulated for the Peace Prize but he
won the Peace Prize that year
nevertheless yes
um so let's talk about that for a
standpoint of a political comparison
we've got Kim Jong-un who now wants to
denuclearize and come to the bargaining
table with Donald Trump do you see a
Nobel Prize in Donald Trump's future you
know there was actually
um a report that uh just two weeks ago
that someone forwarded me that he was uh
nominated for the Nobel Peace Prize not
once but twice recently and then it said
underneath it it said but this this is
this is being investigated as a case of
Fraud and I thought that's weird because
you know nobody should know who
submitted the Nobel Prize nominations
and uh because it's kept secret get this
uh my identity if I didn't expose myself
uh would have been kept secret for 50
years so longer than the JFK Warren
Commission assassination files okay so
for some reason which I speculate about
in the book The Nobel committee is has
wrapped up in this inscrutable you know
non-transparent opaque process uh that
involves you know deep secrets of the
Swedish State and and so it was actually
brought to my attention that in other
prizes the nomination and the nominee
the nominees identities are not made
kept secret and one of those prizes the
Peace Prize so ironically if he had been
nominated for the physics prize you know
there would have been no way for them to
to expose this or to know that the
person had been nominated in a
fraudulent way
um I wouldn't hold my breath I mean
there have been some real Whoppers in
the in the Nobel Peace Prize you know I
say in the book Obama's award is
perfectly consistent with the rules of
the Nobel committee which is what I
think is is a little bit you know I mean
these These are swedes right so they're
they're very fixated on on on on getting
all the very detail-oriented right so
they're going to adhere to things and
and in a perfunctory manner that that
you know and I don't begrudge them for
that but according to the rules Obama
was perfectly eligible uh but we say in
the book and just recently uh you know
report from the committee chair that
year admitted that he made a mistake I
don't talk about whether or not he made
a mistake I think they've chosen some
good people they've chosen some bad
people but this notion that they're
ineffable that they're infallible that
they make you know they make these these
decisions that then coronate people as I
discuss in the book to the level of
deities to the laureates I think I claim
that there's no higher honor you know
you could you couldn't say of an Oscar
winner or of a of a Pulitzer Prize
winner or of a Latin Grammy winner that
they have the stature that the Nobel
Prize affords on you know on normal
human beings and that's true in The
Sciences as well
yeah and it's interesting because we
talk about uh you know that the folks
that are out there that maybe not
politically
um well let's just say they're not
Towing the political line uh that a lot
of folks in academics do today
um like William happer or whatever it
may be that that we've both mentioned
here
um but when you when you have
um somebody like a William happer
talking about
um climatologists that are out there
they're very much focused on grants
right they're focused on getting
government money so that they can you
know obviously run their departments and
do what they need to do and there's a
lot of politics that are involved in
even coming down to the way that uh
research is actually done because they
want uh to obviously come up with the
right results quote unquote right uh do
you see that as as a problem with
Scientists generally speaking whether
it's in
um you know whether it's in your your
your branch of um science or whether
it's across the board where you really
want to try to win a prize that's the
goal here and that in fact impacts the
science itself yeah I mean departments
in my field will you know be ranked by
the number of laureates that they have
the you know they'll they'll be you know
kind of University holidays declared
they'll be you know people and donors
will be brought in to meet with these
winners Etc and so the Nobel Prize being
the highest Accolade that in all of on
all of science if not all of humanity
that they're they're really elevated to
a very small group of people I mean
there are more you know people that have
been on the the space station in the
last couple of years than there are
living Nobel laureates and physics say
because the age is getting so old and
because there's just their maximum of
three of them awarded each year so the
book kind of tackles this notion of of
idolatry and of hero worship and and how
there are many elements in the Nobel
Prize that are reminiscent of religion
and I call it the religion of you know
nobleism uh with its you know Founding
Father its patron saints it's high holy
days and it's uh share of gilded graven
images and so the the notion of of you
know achieving an achievement you know I
thought back to a story that I heard
once about uh young Olympic aspirants
that a test called the Goldman Goldman's
test was done in the 80s I believe it
was I scored sports psychologist and he
asked these young Olympic hopefuls if
they would um take a pill which would
guarantee them Olympic gold and was
untestable and undetectable but it would
cause them to die at age 35 and half of
them accepted that and and it's just
really distressing because I mean what
do you I mean you have so much to live
for in life is so wonderful and
beautiful so that was was right and I
wonder well what about scientists you
know hopefully they're more rational but
but but in a lot of ways you know we're
subject to the same forces the same
desires the same need for credit for and
the same uh competitive forces and we
don't like to share things we certainly
don't like to share credit if we don't
have to and the Nobel Prize underlies a
lot of that and I think you know in many
ways the Nobel Prize can be at its best
kind of a a playful little game but at
worst it can cause tremendous amounts of
pressure and there are many people that
are so obsessed with it that I I just
wish that they would receive the Nobel
Prize so they'd stop talking about it
and what about the competitive app
aspect of the Nobel Prize does that
impact the science itself as well yeah I
think I think it does I mean there have
been studies shown well first of all Let
Me Tell your your listeners and viewers
that the Nobel Prize at most can be won
by three people in physics that's not
true of the Peace Prize for example the
Peace Prize can be won by thousands of
people as indeed happened when Al Gore
won half of the prize and about you know
500 other scientists some of whom my
colleagues here in San Diego shared it
for global warming you know attempt
bringing attention to global warming so
other prizes are able to win uh to win
multiple people are allowed to win but
in the physics prize they've restricted
it to three now in my experiment that I
spoke about earlier called bicep that
experiment had 49 collaboration members
on it any one of whom if we're Miss if
they were missing the experiment would
have wouldn't have succeeded some played
a bigger role you know I think I played
a pretty big role in that I created the
experiment
um and then there were other people that
took it over after I you know kind of
left left the scene I was still a part
of it but uh but you know if we had been
missing any one of them it would have
been meant the end of the experiment and
so uh I think the Nobel Prize sets up
this this you know kind of antiquated
mentality that there's a lone genius or
at most a Troika you know and they're
sitting there and they're scratching
their white beards you know and they're
almost always men
um they've only been two women that ever
won the physics prize and one first one
115 years ago in the second one 54 years
ago so it's it's really not reflective I
mean half my colleagues are women right
so so I'd love it if the if the if the
prize were you know not subject to these
these forces which I believe are are for
its own detriment I think if they don't
change it the competitive climate is
going to cause you know scientists to be
disillusioned with it and they'll
eventually they'll boycott it and when
that happens it's all over because the
Monopoly you know is maintained on this
prize based on its Rarity and the
authority that it conveys upon people
that that win it and I think of some
somebody rejects it and says look it's
this false god and you know just like an
Oscar you know more people don't win the
Oscar then yeah I don't know about you
but I didn't win an Oscar last year
either you know I did win the Nobel
Prize but I also didn't win the Oscar so
more people are losing it and more
people are being shut out of it than
ever and I don't think that's a
sustainable model for this Prize or any
other
so other than the diversity of not just
thought but also demographics gender
specifically uh what other reforms would
you like to see
so I asked myself well why do they why
do they do what they do why do they for
example once they've given a Nobel Prize
they never go back and say well we were
we missed this one other person who
we've been identified as someone who
should have won the Nobel Prize there's
a woman named Rosalind Franklin who
played a huge role in the discovery of
DNA that went to Watson and Crick so she
was left out probably for multiple
reasons
um you know the female aspect but also
she had died by the time the committee
got around to awarding Watson and Crick
and um and so they have this arbitrary
policy that that if you died even if you
die the day before the awards ceremony
they are under no obligation to give it
to you they have given it to away
posthumously and guess who they gave it
to in the past examples where they
intentionally gave it away posthumously
it was to two white Swedish men so
um so so you know I think of them as a
big Corporation I mean they have billion
dollar evaluation they're kind of like a
unicorn right and uh and they're they're
you know the prestigious is based on the
on the on the scarcity of of what they
give away so there are plenty of prizes
worth way more than the Nobel Prize it's
you know I wouldn't turn it down right I
say you know one of the ways to test my
sincerity is offer me the prize and see
if I accept it or not that's a chunk of
change for that right it's a million
dollars but yeah then there's taxes
right and then it gets divided three
ways there are prizes that are worth
individuals get three million dollars in
physics so I think they're you know but
they're nowhere near as prestigious and
every one of them would trade the Nobel
it would trade those prizes for a Nobel
Prize because it's it's been elevated to
this idolatry you know level of idolatry
that's unmatched in in society and
Humanity
um
well yeah so
if we were to wrap it all up there is
politics in this and I don't know if
it's left versus right politics it
sounds like it's it's it's more uh based
upon Dogma or I mean how would you
classify that policy yeah I mean it's
it's really having a checkered past I
mean it's it's had it's early years as
you probably know we're we're you know
really checkered with the stain of
anti-Semitism Einstein was denied a
Nobel Prize for 16 or 17 years right
right Hitler's chief of Aryan physics a
guy named Leonard would not allow him
they had a written rule Einstein must
not win a Nobel Prize that was a thing
Aryan physics Aryan physics yeah you
could get your degree in and I don't
know if you could but but it was
considered experimental physics which is
ironic because that's what I do as a Jew
today
um so he'd be turning in his grave uh
but uh but the politics you know they
use their their uh these the stature
that they have as a platform so if you
listen to the ceremonies you'll hear
things like when in 2017 when the Nobel
Prize was awarded or in late 20 2016
when the Nobel Prize was awarded two
years ago uh that was around the time
when I was after the election of Donald
Trump in the in the in the chairman of
the Nobel Foundation got up and went on
a 15-minute introduction about how all
the winners and the Sciences were all
immigrants and how we need to have open
borders and and we need to have and it
was really a political you know kind of
grandstanding uh event that that was a
little and it went on from you know 15
minutes or something like that before
they got to the actual business at hand
which is rewarding somebody for
discovering a new topological phase of
matter now what does that have to do
with Paul nothing but right they use the
platform they use the Renown they use
the Nobel name for their political
sometimes social engineering purposes
and certainly you know they've used the
Peace Prize and the economics prize uh
which was sued by Nobel nobel's a great
grand nephew
um because it violate it was done purely
politically to reward people with which
the Swedish or the the Swedish Academy
the Swedish Central Bank agreed with so
I think there's there's definitely
latent politics there
um less so in the Sciences uh but but
again The Sciences are vulnerable if
they don't reform in the same way that
you know the Nobel Peace Prize was sued
the Nobel economics prize was sued
you're no longer called it's no longer
called the Nobel prize in economics so
um I I I wrote it as sort of a Jeremiah
ad and a call Clarion cult for reform in
general but also as a way for scientists
to be introspective about what really
motivates a person to do what they do
well let's hope a lot of people read
this especially the scientists and those
folks in Sweden and uh maybe they will
take a lot of what you say to heart and
uh I'm sure a lot of people will
acknowledge you know some of the faults
that they have there so hopefully things
can improve uh Brian where can folks
find you so I'm on uh Twitter at Dr
Brian Keating uh on Twitter which all
one word yeah
b-r-i-a-n-k-e-a-t-i-n-g and I have a
website Brian keating.com
b-r-i-n-k-e-a-t-i-n-g and when's the
book coming out the book is out on April
24th it's published by w w Norton and uh
yeah I'm looking forward to getting
feedback from not only scientists but
but anyone who's ever aspired to to uh
to Great Accolade and fame and and and
like me not gotten into his or her
personal Promise Land yeah yeah and uh
congratulations in order you're
expanding your family so I know the next
few weeks with the book coming out and
the family it's going to be a busy time
for you
yeah best wishes with everything thank
you for joining us and uh folks you can
find us at whiskeypolitics.net also at
ricochet.com don't forget to uh
subscribe to us on iTunes and your
favorite podcast app and give us a five
star rating and comment if you enjoy the
show special thanks again to Brian
Keating professor of physics at the
center of astrophysics and space
Sciences at UCSD we'll be back again
real soon at Whiskey politics
foreign